Hey, how's it going, bras Ma name is POOODIPAAHH i moved office again as you can see...
...for another time.
I'm in this new space, it's pretty cool. It's my own space.
It's definitely my... *laughs*
pahla-a-a
Y O U  P I C K E D  T H E  W R O N G  H O U S E  F O O O O O O O O O O O O
Jack: This is mine. My padded cell Felix: I knew you were insane
Felix: I knew you were one of those people with that-
Felix: *claps* We're going to do Five Weird Stuff Online
Felix: With Jackspedicey.
(music plays)
Felix: Item Number One.
Jack: What are you going to start with?
Felix: I don't know.
Both: *lame laugh*
Felix: Let's go with the biggest. I have this bag of a bunch of shit I bought online.
Jack: Oh my God, Santa-sama
Felix: Okay, let's start with something lame, but I kind of want to try it out.
Jack: What's it called? AIRZOOKA?
Felix: Yeaaah!
Jack: It's like twice the size of that kid.
Felix: I feel like the scale is not...
Jack: Perspective?
Felix: Look at that
Jack: *laughs*
Felix: Heh
Felix: So this is an bazooka
Felix: Seems like too much effort to put together.
Jack: No, it looks cool!
Jack: The fuck is all this?
Jack: Looks like something fucking Megaman uses
Felix: It does yeah, actually
Felix: Maybe I should read the instructions
Jack: *laughs*
Felix: Are you ready to get airzooked? (screaming)
Felix: What are you doing?
Jack: I'm- I'm zooking ;)
Jack: ..Bazinga.
Felix: BAZINGA
Felix: Are you ready to get airzookad, bruuh?
Jack: No-
Jack: You have to pull like this
Felix: I knew that
Jack: *giggles*
Felix: Oh shit, okay, I get it
Felix: How close?
Jack: I don't know.
Both: *laugh*
Felix: You scared now, boy?
Felix: You were making fun of it before!
Felix: I can see your stupid face through here as well.
F L O O P
Jack: Oh my God! *laughs*
Felix: Was it bad?
Jack: Just POW!!!
Felix: *breaks airzooka* OH, SHIT!
Both: AIRZOOKA?! *rip*
Felix: NOOO!
Jack: Okay
Felix: Hit me, bro
Felix: I'm ready *mad pewds*
Jack: Ya ready, boi?
Jack: *imitates Felix* You blink,
y o u  l o s e.
(airzookafail.mp3)
Both: *giggle*
Jack: This thing fucking sucks ;)
*Jack blows air towards Felix*
Felix: A A A A H H H H
Jack: AIRZOOKA!
Felix: Thank God there was cover here
Felix: Did you break it for real?
Jack: No the- ohh yeah.
*rip jack again*
Both: *laugh*
Jack: That works really well.
Felix: Do it..
Both: *Laugh*
Felix: Jesus-
Jack: It's the sound as well
Felix: Yeah, it kinda scares you
Felix: 3... 2... 1...
*le fabulous jump boi*
Jack: Aaww
Felix: Yeeeaah!!
Jack: Don't look at me
Felix: How do I look like? *ur a bat pewds*
Jack: Uhh, so fucking weird.
Felix: *im scared*
Jack: Come close to the camera
Felix: *hisses*
Felix: I can't see anything
Jack: Okay too close, too close, you're good.
Jack: Oh my God
Felix: I can't even see myself in-
Felix: OH MY GOOOOOOD!
Felix: Your outfit
Jack: Really nice
Felix: Very nice
Jack: Very nice, very flowy.
Felix: Very nice! *handok.mp3*
Felix: I like it, jak sie masz.
Felix: When you put it on was remembering, when I was 5 at kindergarten
Felix: I played Peter Pan
Jack: Ooh
Felix: Yeah, and I had the exactly that outfit
Felix: But it was borrowed
Felix: so I was like, well it's not mine so should I.. remove my underwear?
Jack: WHAT?
Felix: I don't know I was like, that's kinda gross.
Jack: It's more gross when you have no underwear!
Felix: I was a kid okay?!
Felix: So I went naked out on stage with it.
Jack: Wait, like this?
Felix: Yes!
Jack: Oooh, bold move.
Felix: Hell yeah!
Felix: Alright. Let's see what we have here.
Jack: Think I saw something in there, I'm excited.
Felix: What did you see?
Jack: I'm not telling.
Jack: I'm not telling, Felix. I want board game!
Felix: Boi game?
Jack: Board game... But yeah, sure. You have fluff on your beard.
Felix: Shut up!
Jack: *mumbles* Wish I had wings...
Jack: What?
Felix: Don't you worry, Jackspedicey 5!
Felix: I got the Robo Twist!
Jack: OH MY GOOOOOOD!
Felix: It can twist anything!
Felix: It probably needs batteries, I just realised.
Jack: I'm excited for this one.
Jack: If only there was like a drone that like flew down on to it, then you could twist
Felix: There would be no effort whatsoever
Jack: If only we had another Robo Twist to get the box open!
Felix: Alright, you ready?
Both: Whoa whoa whoa!
Jack: Calm down, Robo Twist!
Felix: Stop twisting, Robo Twist!
Felix: It's no stop
Felix: oogh-
Jack: Fucking machines. You can't trust them.
Felix: Alright. AAAH!
Jack: AAHH!
Jack: Carefully.
Both: *scream*
Felix: How does it work?
Jack: I don't know
Felix: Yeah!
Jack: Oh!
Felix: YEAH.
Jack: Robo Twist!
Felix: ROBO TWISTTT
Both: ROBO TWIST
Felix: ROBO TWIST
ROBO TWIST- oh
Felix: OHHH
Both: OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHHHH
Jack: I was almost expecting this whole thing to shatter in our hands-
*Both laugh*
Felix: It's not stopping
Jack: It just want to keep on twisting.
Felix: It just wants to keep on- *laughs*
Jack: It's just gonna crush it..
Felix: AAAAHHHH
Jack: NIPPLE TWIST!
Jack: That was amazing!
Felix: What could possibly beat that item? *Both laugh*
Jack: What beats Robo Twist?
Felix: I've been wanting to use these, for a long time
Felix: Since we have matching outfits and all...
Jack: Yess!
Felix: ...We get matching, uhh...
Both: Otamatones!
Jack: That's what I saw in the box and I'm so fucking happy.
Jack: Except we might need batteries for these as well
Felix: You need batteries for these as well?
Jack: Yeah
Felix: *whispers* Fuck Jacksepticeye.
Felix: I can play myself..
Jack: You cursing me out?
Felix: No.
Jack: Bitch.
Felix: *whispers* He's a bitch.
Jack: Stab you
Felix: *chuckles* Jesus Christ
Felix: So what's more annoying than two loud-ass Youtubers?
*Otamatones make high-pitched whining sounds*
Jack: It's like I'm looking into an audio mirror.
*Otamatone makes a very high-pitched sound*
Felix: Oh my God, stop. Jesus Christ.
Jack: *laughs*
Felix: We have to play something together.
Jack: Wait.
*Otamatones make sounds*
Jack: I don't know
Felix: That was jammin'
Jack: There was- no, there was a was a Zelda-thing I learned
*Otamatone makes a tune*
Felix: What the fuck is that?
Jack: Duu, du du du dududuuu
Felix: Oooh!
Both: *laugh*
Felix: Do it again
*meme music 101 plays*
Jack: Aren't you Sweden's number one orchestra player?
Felix: That I- that I am, thank you!
*Otamatones make high-pitched sounds*
Jack: They're so fucking cute though.
*Otamatones make sounds*
*Otamatones make a very high-pitched sound*
*Otamatones high pitched sound intensifies*
*Both laugh*
Felix: What could possibly be better- oh shit I realised I have fucking wings and shit!
Felix: AH! SHI-
Both: *laugh*
Felix: Jack, do you like reading?
Jack: uhm.
Jack: no.
Felix: Well, I have something for you!
Jack: Whoa! The Lazy Readers?
Felix: -The Lazy Readers!
Jack: What the fuck are the Lazy Readers? *giggles*
Jack: Are they mirror glasses?
Felix: They are mirror glasses, BOI.
Jack: OOH.
Felix: They match your outfit *laughs*
Jack: Oh my God, that's so weird- I'm like walking and looking at my own feet.
*Both laugh*
Felix: Hey whaddup, BOI?!
Jack: Oh Jesus Christ!
Both: *laugh*
Felix: I see- *laughs*
Jack: Can you see-
Felix: Wait, wait, I gotta show you... Can you see your fucking eyes?
*Both laugh*
Jack: Can you see me, boi?
Jack: I don't know if you can see cos of the lights
Felix: It's probably- OH I see, I see, yeah!
Both: *laugh*
Jack: Those are so weird
Felix: Whoa, it's like I'm playing a video game.
Jack: And- They're so clear as well.
Felix: I see my knob as well. That's great.
Felix: Oh hell yeah, I get it!
Jack: Yeah! *laughs*
Felix: I get it! This is awesome!
Both: *laugh*
Felix: Wait, where are you?
Jack: Ooh my God
Felix: This one I bought... it had bad reviews-
Felix: *laughs* Stop doing that, it's so fucking creepy.
Felix: Oh shit- WOAH. WOAH.
Jack: Woahh-
Felix: WOAH.
Felix: Hell yeh!
Jack: ..You've wings though so it doens't work-
Jack: That's really fucking cool!
Felix: AAH
Felix: Alright, pass it along-
Felix: -You ready for the pass-along?
Jack: *mutters* ah yeh, fucking-
Both: *laugh*
Jack: Now we're just holding hands!
Felix: You ready for the pass-along?
Both: WHOOOOAAAAH!
Felix: Back at it again!
Jack: With the white vaaaa-
Felix: AAAAAAAAH!
Felix: The last item...
Jack: *mumbles* That's fuckin' cool.
Felix: The last item, Jack. Are you ready?
Jack: I am.
Jack: Love this, totally life-changing bra.
Felix: Life-changing bra. Well, we just gonna have to see about that.
Jack: This is an actual bra?
Felix: Yeah, I didn't know your size..
Felix: I went with an A-cup.
Jack: Yeah, that's- that's probably accurate.
Felix: Eww
Felix: Ahh no.
Felix: Ohh...
Jack: Oh nice.
Felix: Ooohohhoho
Felix: Oooh yeah!
Felix: Well, this just.. became really gay.
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Jack: PooDiePie channel 2017.
Felix: Do you need help with that?
Felix: You look like uhh,  like a hawaiian girl or something.
Felix: *laughs*
Jack: These are my coconuts.
Felix: Alright, well that was- *laughs*
Jack: This is YouTube 2017 - loud noises and nudity!
Felix: Leave a like and check out Jack for some reason, if you haven't.
Felix: And as always
Felix: gayfister
Jack: What does it sound like when a thousand Jacksepticeyes get together? *giggles*
*Otamatones make a very high-pitched sound*
*Jack and Felix play the Otamatones*
Both: *giggle*
Jack: It's 'Darude - Sandstorm'!
Felix: *laughs*
*Jack attempts human music with Otamatone*
Felix: Surely we'll figure out how to play...
Felix: Oh that was the right tune!
Jack: Yeah!
*Otamatones play tunes*
Jack: *giggles*
*Felix attempts to copy Jack*
Jack: That's pretty good.
Felix: We'll take it!
Both: *laugh*..